senate democrats just passed a 740
billion dollar bill called the inflation
reduction act during a 16-hour marathon
voting procedure known as vote arama
the bill
does a lot of things it sets aside
369 billion dollars to line the pockets
of the democrats pals in the green
energy industry
it extends obamacare subsidies for an
extra year it raises all sorts of taxes
on different groups and corporations it
even increases taxes on gas and oil
imports which is pretty wild because gas
and oil prices are probably the single
greatest driver of inflation so you're
going to raise taxes on that going to
make the costs go up doesn't seem to
make a lot of sense pretty much pretty
much the only thing that the inflation
reduction act does not do
is reduce inflation as the pen wharton
budget model showed last week and as 88
percent of democrats already know
according to a recent yougov poll and as
even bernie sanders admits when he
refers to the behemoth legislation as
the quote so-called inflation reduction
act these are not my words these are not
the words of ted cruz or donald trump
these are bernie sanders words quote i
say so-called because according to the
cbo and other economic organizations
that have studied this bill it will in
fact have a minimal impact on inflation
it's not my best the fouchy's better but
you get the point the democrats voted
for this stuff anyway and they voted for
it not because it will reduce inflation
but because it gives them a lot of the
dumb legislative agenda that they've
wanted for a very long time
even leading democrats cannot muster an
economic argument for it least of all
joe biden
seven nobel laureates in the in the
economy on the economist and the
economics i should say
not only can joe biden not muster an
economic argument for the bill
he cannot even say the word economic
the whole sorry spectacle is just more
evidence of a disturbing trend that i
have mentioned on this show before
the libs are not even trying to make
arguments anymore this is a really big
shift and very few people are talking
about it in the old days the libs would
at least try to mask their power grabs
and their personal interests in the
language of logic and reason and the
common good
usually it was bs but hypocrisy is the
tribute vice pays to virtue increasingly
today that kind of language is gone
the arguments are gone
even the facade of reasoned debate and
civic spirit
is gone
now in lieu of an argument the libs are
just redefining all the terms
can't argue why men should be allowed
into the women's bathroom
no problem just redefine woman there you
go you don't need to make an argument
now can't explain why your crappy
economic policies destroyed the economy
oh that's not a big deal you just have
to redefine recession then presto
changeo no problem
and now we'll just keep refreshing
wikipedia and merriam-webster because
sooner or later they're going to
redefine inflation too i'm michael
knowles this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment on friday is from harry martins
who says
imagine had brittany griner been caught
in singapore or malaysia russia right
now looks like a walk in the park by
comparison that's true people are we'll
get to brittany greiner maybe a little
bit later in the show but people are
talking about how you know this is the
end of the world brittany griner has
been sentenced to prison because she
smuggled drugs into russia
other countries would be harsher okay
there are russia's not even the harshest
country on drugs people talk about
america's drug policy as being an
outlier yes it is an outlier not in the
harshness we have on drugs but in our
leniency we are insanely lenient on
drugs that's why that's a lot of the
reason why our life expectancy is
declining because so many people are
hooked on drugs and odin left and right
maybe we could learn a lesson here from
what's going on in russia
this bill that just came out of the
senate is
absolutely terrible and the democrats
rammed it through because they have no
accomplishments so far this year and the
midterms are approaching so they've got
to have something to hang their hats on
and they had to twist joe manchin's arm
and kirsten cinema's arm and they tried
to bring all the moderates in line and
it passes with a tie-breaking vote from
the vice president kamala harris but it
was just terrible and the procedure they
used is called vote-a-rama vote-a-rama
is this procedure that allows senators
to propose an unlimited number of
amendments to budget-related measures
and then they bring up the amendments
they can vote on them they can shoot
them down and it this can go on for 12
hours 14 hours went on 16 hours to get
this stupid
inflation reduction act through that's
not going to reduce inflation whatsoever
the only silver lining here
is because the senators can propose all
these sorts of amendments they can
really highlight the hypocrisy of the
people who are in the majority who are
cramming this through so some republican
senators did that marco rubio in
particular
rubio's thinking okay we're going to get
this dumb bill there's no way to stop
that but at least we can get democrats
on the record for their insane
priorities one of which is this marco
rubio
proposes to limit
federal pregnancy subsidies
to
women to the only people who can
actually get pregnant
and
you know it
all the democrats shoot it down
well thank you mr president um
a few minutes ago i look back
across 5 500 years of human history so
far every single pregnancy has been a
biological female and so therefore the
only thing i'm trying to do is make sure
that federal law is clear that since
every pregnancy that's ever existed has
been in a biological female that our
federal laws reflect that and our
pregnancy programs are available to the
only people who are capable of getting
pregnant biological females very simple
i would accept a unanimous consent if
they want to offer it and we can move on
and not waste any time
senator murray has 10 seconds left
when we are facing the challenges we do
in this country when we're facing
challenges in this country and helping
our constituents to lower costs it is
outrageous that republicans are trying
to define pregnancy of all things on
this floor on this day after hours of
voting on amendments i urge a no vote
it is outrageous that republicans want
to limit pregnancy funding to women
outrageous and what does patty murray
say she doesn't want to go all the way
and and admit that the democrats are now
it is the official line of the democrats
that men can become pregnant that men
can be women and vice versa so she says
we don't have time for this
you don't have time for this lady you've
been voting for 16 hours wasting
everybody's time on this absolute
nonsense now you're telling me all that
we don't have any time to have a
unanimous consent up up or down vote on
whether women are really women whether
men men can become pregnant or not we
don't have time for this of course of
course we have time they just don't want
to do it because the the libs now
believe that men can become pregnant so
this was a great great bit from rubio i
think it's a great idea it it was good
as a political stunt and also it should
be voted on and it should pass
unanimously
however i have one little thing that
bugs me about rubio's stunt
can we please stop using the phrase
biological females
can we please stop using them
she is a biological female
he's a biological male stop it stop it
that phrase
grants the left's entire premise because
when you say i limit it to biological
females you are implying that there is
some other kind of female
that you could maybe be a biological
male but a spiritual female or a
non-biological female or a psychological
female or whatever which is the
democrats whole point the democrats
whole point is that you can be a
biological female but in your gender
expression you can be a male or not a
male or a female or something in between
or whatever
and the conservatives point
is that sex and gender expression
are and ought to be
extremely similar or the same
yes you can be a girl and kind of a
tomboy yes you can be a fella and a
little bit light in the loafers but your
your sex and your gender
are essentially the same thing and they
ought to be the same thing that's our
point so you you don't need to use this
phrase biological female he's a
biological male you just say man or
woman that will suffice
and actually it's the only coherent way
to make our argument um this really bugs
me because
i the the manipulation of language is a
little bit of a hobby horse of mine i
wrote an entire book on it called
speechless controlling words controlling
minds which all you wonderful people out
there made a number one national
bestseller but this is the way that the
democrats control the political order
they don't even necessarily do it
through votes or through big campaigns
very often the way that they do it is
just by subtly shifting all the language
and then they win the debate before it
even takes place and that's what's
happening with biological female so just
cut it out it's a great idea i love the
whole thing rubio's so right to put
forward an amendment to say we're going
to limit funding to women but we got to
cut it out with the qualifiers the
biological the spiritual psychological
non-biological speaking of misusing
words
uh
the
the president of the united states joe
biden is i think the democrat par
excellence here in terms of the
manipulation of language he's trying to
redefine everything he's trying to
redefine recession he's trying to
redefine
all all sorts of issues
sometimes though this manipulation of
language confuses the
senile commander in chief to the point
that he forgets that he's the president
you know i know most families are
focused on just putting three mills on
the
table
taking care of their kids and paying
their bills
helping you do that is my job
that's a president's job as well
that's my job and it's the president's
job as well
he's kind of proving his point here by
the way that joe biden is practically
speaking not really the president he's
kind of proving that point because he
clearly didn't write what's on the
teleprompter he didn't even read it they
just put stuff in front of him and he
tries to read it usually unsuccessfully
so yes it's almost certainly the case
that other people around joe biden are
calling the shots because biden doesn't
know which end is up
however it is it is worth pointing out a
lot of conservatives will will recoil at
this idea that it's part of the
president's job is just creating good
communities and making sure that people
are flourishing and having a good life a
lot of the libertarians especially will
recoil at that idea they did recoil at
that when when
donald trump said the same thing in
2016. he said well what i want to do is
i want i want you to have good
communities if i'm president i'm going
to give you good communities i'm going
to give you a good life and you're all
going to flourish and it's going to be
great and the libertarians kind of
recoiled at that they said no your job
is just to basically do nothing and to
leave me alone
he's right he's right in principle trump
was right when he said it biden was
right when he tried to say it
the slip for biden was he said and
that's the president's job as well when
he was supposed to say and that's the
president's job as well right the
emphasis was on the wrong place he was
supposed to suggest that he is the
president not that someone else is the
president but regardless the point that
the speechwriter wrote in there is true
the president is the symbol of the
government he is the head of state and
the government yes protects all of our
liberty but the point is to ensure the
blessings of liberty that's what you see
in the constitution and if you've got a
crappy country where everyone's dying
and killing each other and and the
country itself is falling apart then all
the pie in the sky ideology abstract
ideas on a napkin in the world are not
going to do anything that buck 50 will
get you a cup of coffee
until joe biden becomes president
in which case you need like 750 to get a
cup of coffee because of rampant
inflation when you want to protect
yourself not just your country not just
your community but your data you've got
to check out expressvpn
right now go to expressvpn.com
knowles what if there were someone out
there who kept a log of every single
thing you did every minute of the day
that would probably be pretty creepy
right
what if i told you that is exactly what
happens every time you go online your
internet provider is allowed to store
logs of every website you have ever
visited and can legally sell these data
to anyone that is why you gotta use
expressvpn i love expressvpn i trust
them on all my devices that is what i
use to secure my internet connection
through their secure servers so my isp
can't see or log what i do online many
vpns claim to have a no logs policy but
they've been caught logging customer
activity expressvpn is the only vpn i
trust because they use trusted server
technology they were the first major vpn
provider to engineer all of their vpn
servers to run in ram and you don't have
to take my word or expressvpn's word for
it they had one of the biggest assurance
firms pwc pricewaterhousecoopers audit
their technology it's no wonder that the
verge named expressvpn the number one
vpn in the world stop letting people
keep logs of what you do online go to
expressvpn.com knowles right now find
out how you can get three months for
free
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com knowles
expressvpn.com slash nols head on over
there right now to learn more
speaking of our broader ruling class
speaking of the people who are really
calling the shots when joe biden says
you know look it's my job and it's the
president's job too you know whatever
whatever these people are putting in
front of me telling me leading me around
like a marionette when we're talking
about the ruling class not just in the
government but in the media in big tech
in the
education system and all over the pla in
the financial system in what
corporations
they tend to
set their narrative and they stick to
the script
and sometimes the narrative changes you
are seeing that happen right now this is
a little reported on story but it's it's
pretty jarring
the media
are shifting the narrative on ukraine
when i'm referring to a jarring story
i'm not even talking about the ukraine
story i'm talking about the story of the
media shifting their narrative on
ukraine what we had been told
up until this moment
is that
ukraine is not just a
eastern european country that was
invaded by russia but ukraine is the
symbol of the west we are ukraine slava
ukraine this is it this is the last
stand for democracy we need to focus all
of our efforts we need to put all of our
resources into defending ukraine
vladimir zelinski he is the greatest
ruler in the history of the world this
country is absolutely pristine
you obviously
uh we we've got to
just totally focus on saving the country
okay
send them all the money send them all
the weapons maybe send them some of our
fighters too
now the the same media were pushing that
idea and changing all their little
avatars on social media to include the
ukraine flag and running all these puff
pieces on ukraine
now they're changing the narrative this
story just came out of cbs news that the
vast majority of the funding were in the
weapons that were sending to ukraine
are disappearing
we're seeing this incredible historic
flow of weapons coming into ukraine do
we have any sense as to
where they're going
we don't know there is really no
information as to where they're going uh
at all you know all this stuff goes
above the border and they're kind of
like something happens it kind of like
you
thirty percent maybe which is six five
destination thirty percent are you
concerned about weapons getting in the
wrong hands i don't care at all whether
that happens what sort of a unit do you
commit
can't say
okay the u.s has sent tens of thousands
of anti-aircraft and anti-armor systems
artillery rounds hundreds of artillery
systems switchblade armored drones and
tens of millions of rounds of small arms
ammunition
but in a conflict where front lines are
scattered and conditions change without
warning
not all of those supplies reach their
destination
what
some of us have been saying this sort of
thing for months
the conservatives have been saying this
sort of thing for months and the media
cbs news and all the rest of them have
accused us of being pro-putin
pro-russia undermining democracy
authoritarian all this kind of crap and
now
they're saying exactly the same thing
for months we've been saying hey are you
sure we should be sending all these
weapons over here ukraine is actually
kind of a corrupt country actually
there's there's a little bit more going
on right here than i think is being
reported on in the press and they say
you're a putin stooge
if you don't want to send bazillions of
dollars worth of weapons to ukraine and
escalate into a a
more and more direct war with russia a
nuclear former superpower well you're
just a stooge you're undemocratic you're
anti-american or whatever and now
they're running the same sort of story
we haven't talked about ukraine in a
little while because the war has become
basically just a war of attrition
they're just going to duke this out
forever even though in the first days of
the war we were told by all the geniuses
this is going to be over in three or
four days it's held out it's a little
bit of a stalemate the operation's
ongoing the war has really been going on
since long before the russian invasion
of this greater part of ukraine it's
been going on since at least 2014.
really this conflict has been going on
much much longer
not even just back to the early days of
the soviet union this conflict's been
going on it dates back a thousand years
so my entire position on ukraine from
the very beginning has been
it's complicated
and i know i think that's the least
popular position of all because everyone
wants you to be either we need to go
i'll go fly over to ukraine send in
101st airborne vladimir zelinski's
winston churchill or you you see some
people who are reactionary they say
russia is totally in the right actually
we we if you really think about it
vladimir putin is a really strong good
guy or whatever and and my opinion on
the war is
it's complicated
it's complicated it is
why did this war break out
well vladimir zelinski himself says it's
because joe biden went weak on the
russian oil sanctions and i i think he's
quite right there why else did the war
break at is it in part because the
united states was obviously very
involved in the maidan revolution in
2014 yeah i think that was probably part
of it
and you've seen people from the
uh foreign apparatus of the united
states who have essentially admitted
that in recent weeks
is it because nato expanded eastward is
it because after the fall of the berlin
wall you had people like george kennan
sam nunn daniel patrick moynihan all
were these are these are tough cold
warriors saying hey guys don't use this
opportunity to expand nato eastward
that's going to unnecessarily antagonize
russia and you're going to increase the
likelihood of a real hot war
and then what happened nato expanded
eastward i think recklessly do you think
that had something to do with the
outbreak of tension there i think
probably it did do you think it had
something to do with the idea that we
formerly had buffer states between these
larger powers the west united states and
europe and and russia on the other side
and then the buffer states went away
now you've got great greater powers up
against one another and that can create
tension and the possibility of war uh
yeah i think i think it all had to do
with that is ukraine an extremely
corrupt country yes it is so is it any
surprise that the majority of money and
ammunition and guns that we're sending
over there is just disappearing going to
the black market somewhere
it's not a surprise to me i guess it's a
surprise to cbs news maybe they should
have tuned into the michael knowles show
and they would have they would have
learned a thing or two now they wouldn't
be so shocked in their report
why are they airing this now
if you go to twitter it's actually hard
to find that clip now it took the clip
down because it started making the
rounds what is this about it could be
one of two things either
the war is not going as the geniuses in
our foreign policy establishment thought
it was going to go and so all of a
sudden after ginning up all of the
americans
eagerness and appetite for war for
ukraine and getting everyone to change
their little profile avatars to the
ukraine flag and getting getting really
really excited about this they realize
huh maybe this isn't the wisest war to
get too involved and now we're going to
kind of tamp that down and we're going
to portray ukraine as a little bit more
corrupt than we previously had that's
one possibility
or the other possibility is
the foreign policy establishment which
absolutely
uh sees ukraine and a lot of the rest of
eastern europe as essential to the
western foreign policy and to containing
russia they are realizing huh our
strategy of just giving guns and
everything to the ukrainians isn't
really working so now we need a little
bit more direct action so what they
might be doing is saying look we still
need to defend ukraine we still have a
great interest in this war but it's not
going to be enough to send them a bunch
of missiles we have to send in our own
guys we need to get more involved in the
war the the way that this plays out in
the media over the coming weeks will
determine which of those two
possibilities it is
but it's a major major narrative shift
and it's a sudden narrative shift and
it's not happening accidentally it's
it's happening because of a change in
strategic thinking with regard to the
war in ukraine speaking of death
and speaking of other things that i'm
obviously right about
you you know i hate to say i told you so
but a lot of these things that we've
been talking about on this show in
particular have just been
jumping to the forefront of the media
and the news i've said for a long time
abortion is not about
freedom abortion is not about the right
to choose and you choose this and i
choose this and you know we all just
kumbaya man i've said abortion is
a religious sacrament that all politics
ultimately is religious if you think
that your politics is not rooted in
religion you're probably you're probably
really superstitious actually you're
you're probably a
involved in a caricature of religion
because necessarily when we're making
moral decisions and ethical decisions
they come down to religion i said
abortion is especially especially
vulnerable to that
there's a video that's going around the
internet of of a young woman who is
teaching other women how to as they
prepare for their abortion and after
their abortion
build an actual altar at which to
worship
building an altar for your abortion can
be a really cathartic procedure can be a
really cathartic process
because
it just creates
a space for your your sacred container
where you can return to
whenever you want to meditate whenever
you want to think deeply or contemplate
any aspect of your abortion it's a
really beautiful way to just give
reference to the experience
and hold the experience
in a really sacred way
i also really like to add the abortion
pills themselves to the altar
to really bless the pills that we're
going to be taking into our bodies
during this process and place the
container
of which you plan to put the the
products of conception
or the fetal remains within
to catch that after you've passed it and
save it for later when we when we find a
way to
to bury or otherwise
to where we find a way to properly
dispose of the fetal remains in a way
that gives reverence and respect and
support to this
to this sacred abortion experience
that's a whole lot of thought and prayer
and liturgy and worship for a
meaningless clump of cells don't you
think
when you want to tune out of this insane
toxic social media big tech environment
and still interact with people but in a
way that's much more conducive to human
flourishing you gotta check out tuvu
right now head on over to tuvu.com
knowles it is time to take a stand and
stop feeding the big tech beast that
wants to cancel us and censor us and
isolate us from one another on social
media you have heard me talk a lot about
tuvu that is the new subscription-based
alternative on social media that weeds
out the bots and the trolls and the
invasive ads and most importantly the
algorithms that make big tech such a
toxic place tuvu is the photo sharing
community app built on family values
data privacy and freedom of opinion it's
time to move our communities our
families and our churches to a better
place online where big tech is not
pushing their agenda their vice their
addictive content and the damaging
material that they have out there to all
of our mental health tuvu is ad-free so
they answer to you the subscriber he who
pays the piper calls the tune unto your
data will never be sold to advertisers
or data miners instead tuvu sells social
media freedom to those who use it for
just 2.99 a month or 22.99 per year that
right there weeds out fakes all along
the way are you hesitant to try a new
platform well for the next seven days
only two vu is giving our listeners a
free annual membership when you go to
tuvu.com you'll get a free annual
membership get all the details and your
free annual subscription for a limited
time only at 2vu.com
head on over there right now do not miss
this opportunity t-u-v-u.com
knowles or look for the tuvu app on
google play or the app store
now this is the moment in the show where
in years past i would have read you an
ad for harry's razors and i would have
said hey you millions of listeners out
there i love harry's and you should go
out and buy harry's but i'm not going to
do that
because i don't love harry's
i hate harry's if you don't know the
story harry's used to advertise on our
shows until
it was me it was a little old me i went
along on a different show years prior
and i agreed with the host's statement
that boys are boys and girls or girls
and this was too much for harry's
aries then pulled their ads because of
quote values misalignment well we're not
going to promote products that hate your
values so we did the only thing that
makes sense we launched our own razor
company jeremy's razors every jeremy's
razors kit comes with a premium razor
two sets of blades shaving cream and
aftershave bomb it's a beautiful thing
to behold over 70 000 kits have already
shipped do not go to harry's dot com go
to
ihateharrys.com get your jeremy's razors
founders kit it's time to stop giving
your money to what corporations that
hate your guts give it to jeremy instead
this video
of this young woman
who is dressed just like the archetypal
millennial woman she's wearing yoga
pants she's in her
studio apartment in probably new york or
something
and she builds an altar
she says on the altar for our abortion
we're gonna put the abortion drug and
then
how spooky is this she says we're gonna
get a jar
that we're gonna put the product of
conception into and then she clarifies
what she means by that euphemism she
says
you know the fetal remains so she's
saying you know put the dead baby into
this little jar on the altar with some
incense with the abortion drugs and
you're going to worship at this sacred
altar
people are looking at this and they're
saying oh my gosh this is so this is the
craziest thing ever all but can you
believe this yes i can believe this
because it's not the craziest thing ever
this is the norm in human history
it is a human sacrifice an actual
visible
undeniable human sacrifice
and that is the norm
not killing babies
is the exception in human history
in christian civilization we say no
human sacrifice no killing our babies no
we try to tamp down eugenics which
is also plays a huge role in abortion
and also has been practiced all around
the world since the dawn of time and the
christian civilization says no we're not
going to have any of that as
christianity declines in public
you're not going to have nothing you're
not going to have a vacuum you're not
going to have
neutrality you're going to have all the
same insane paganism that typifies the
rest of the world throughout all of
history that's going to come flooding
back in as it is with a vengeance
this is the normal state of things
if you don't like that normal state of
things with the human sacrifice and the
bacchanals and the orgies and the the
demon worship and all that kind of stuff
if you don't like that
then it is incumbent upon us
to
re-christianize our political order you
hear the libs crying about christian
nationalism
as the the rise of christian nationalism
as as though this is the worst thing in
the world
christian nationalism is just the
opposite of atheist globalism
atheist globalism weird kooky pagan
wipe away our national borders wipe away
our traditions that's the abortion altar
okay that's the monkey pox orgies taking
place with government sanction that's
that's what that looks like if you don't
want that society your alternative right
now
is christian nationalism and we have not
only the right but the duty
to reimpose a normal
broadly christian society
in in our culture okay we have the right
to do that now what some people say will
say is well you know look abortions are
going to happen
abortions are going to happen
and so either they can be safe or
dangerous first of all no abortion is
safe because it always kills a baby
but second of all even the premise is
kind of flawed
sure yes there will be
some abortions that take place even if
you outlaw abortion and even if you
stigmatize it in society but many fewer
will take place
when we had laws against abortion many
many many fewer abortions took place
if if that argument from the libs is
true look abortions are going to happen
anyway they might as well be legal well
look people are going to use drugs
anyway it might as well be legal well
it's the kind of liberal slash
libertarian argument if that were true
then that would be an argument for
getting rid of all the laws well look
murders are going to take place we might
as well we should just make sure that
murders don't go underground okay you
don't want it to be on we just need it
to be legal and regulated
look uh tax evasion is gonna occur but
we just need it we should have it be
legal we should get rid of all of the
laws and then just have total anarchy
that's that's the conclusion of that but
no of course that's not the case when
you have laws against stuff you get less
of that stuff
abortion obviously should be illegal it
should be stigmatized in society and
that which that sorceress who was
showing you how to build an altar to the
human sacrifice of your of your dead
baby that woman should be totally
ostracized from society and should be so
ashamed that she doesn't show her face
in public that's what should happen
and we should have do that from the
cultural front
but also from the political front
because politics is downstream of
culture but culture is also downstream
of politics they they kind of work in
tandem it's actually very difficult to
differentiate between the two
speaking of love and hate
this story there's a story that i you'll
have to indulge me i am so unreasonably
obsessed with this story and i'm so
elated by the turn of events in this
story
according to page six kim kardashian and
skeet davidson
are breaking up
they are this whirlwind romance
went on for about nine months i think
mr davidson appeared
on some episodes of the kardashian tv
show i've never watched an episode of
the kardashian tv show but he was on it
skeet davidson who came out and was one
of the people breaking up the marriage
between kim kardashian and kanye west a
marriage where they had multiple kids
and skeet comes in
and
he just is a home wrecker
and what happens now they've broken up
and i'm really happy
i'm really happy skeet davidson
actually got kim's initials in the
initials of her children with kanye west
tattooed on his neck that's going to be
very awkward it's going to be a big
payday for skeet davidson's tattoo
removal artist a few lessons here
one lesson is don't get the names of
your thrice married girlfriend's kids
tattooed on your neck that would be
lesson one
but
the second lesson here the it's the real
reason that i'm obsessed with this story
is
it's because i hate attacks on marriage
and yes kim kardashian has been married
multiple times and i don't really know
if those mileages were valid or not
valid
but here's what i do know i know that
kim kardashian and kanye west
had multiple kids together they were
working it out
even in hollywood even with their both
of their eccentric wild personalities
and i was actually depressed when they
split up because i hate attacks on
marriage
i hate undermining marriage not just at
a personal level though i am personally
disgusted by attacks on marriage whether
that be trying to redefine marriage
whether that be trying to weaken
marriage through no fault divorce
whether that any of the attacks on
marriage but i am i am really opposed to
attacks on marriage from a political
level as well because marriage is the
fundamental political unit
so regardless of even our own personal
reactions to that or our own emotional
investment in marriage just from the
level of sheer political order and
political philosophy if you weaken
marriage your society is going to suck
okay because the libs want to convince
us that the individual the atomized
individual is the basic unit of society
and they want to break down all of the
institutions and all of the ties and all
of the families in particular that bind
us all together they want to break us
down into the individual because then
we're much easier to dominate and
control once we're all broken down into
the little individuals they can gather
us up like a bundle of sticks and do
what they want with us that's what the
libs believe
the libertarians also believe that the
individual is the basic unit of society
they don't want to gather us all
together in a bundle of sticks like the
commies do but they do hold the same
basic view of political society the
conservatives have a different view the
conservatives believe no the individual
is not the basic unit of politics
actually politics means public it's the
stuff we do together it's how we live
together in our cities and our states
and our countries and so necessarily
involves multiple people
you see echoes of this when christ
describes his church he says where two
or more of you are gathered there i am
also his description of the church as
something that is public with multiple
people held in common
or participated in in common in in the
body of christ you see that in religion
and you certainly see it in
political society regardless of what
religion
is is considered the animating spirit of
the society just in politics when we're
all together
that involves multiple people okay and
the family is the basic unit of that and
skeet freaking davidson tried to bust up
a family and i'm glad that it failed for
him i'm glad we should be we should be
very pro kanye who is trying to keep his
marriage together
kanye flawed though he may be flawed
though we all are he was trying to keep
his marriage together kim kardashian
embracing just total selfishness she did
a whole magazine spread about how in my
40s i'm just going to do me i'm just
going to do whatever i want to do that's
that's what that's what a mother of
multiple children should do right just
whatever she wants to do is that it no
that's a that's a recipe for a bad
society
and you can you can tell the rotten
fruit of this
the the tree this tree of ideology by
the fact that she dated skeet davidson
who's totally gross and now they broke
up and that's great i'm really happy
about that speaking of family
dick cheney former vice president is
coming out in defense of his daughter
his daughter is getting absolutely
trounced in her her congressional bid in
wyoming because she was a republican and
then she practically speaking switched
sides and now she only ever helps the
democrats and she's the face of the
ridiculous democrat january 6th charade
and on the crucial votes she always
sides with the big libs so in a
last-ditch ever to save her campaign
dick cheney is coming out to defend her
and our nation is 246 history there has
never been an individual who is a
greater threat to our republic than
donald trump he tried to steal the last
election using lies and violence to keep
himself in power after the voters had
rejected him
he was a coward a real man wouldn't lie
to his supporters he lost his election
and he lost big
i know it he knows it and deep down i
think most republicans know it
lynn and i are so proud of liz for
standing up for the truth
doing what's right
honoring her oath to the constitution
when so many in our party are too scared
to do so
liz is fearless she never backs down
from a fight there is nothing more
important she will ever do
then lead the effort to make sure donald
trump is never again near the oval
office
and she will succeed
i am dick cheney i proudly voted for my
daughter i hope you will too
i'm liz cheney and i approve this
message
okay dick cheney wants to defend his
daughter
he's a good dad okay okay fine i'm not
going to criticize him for defending his
daughter it's good to defend your
daughter good to defend your family
but come on man the claims that this
guy's making in our nation's entire
history
donald trump is the most dangerous
figure ever in american history
the the most dangerous ever how about um
aaron burr you know aaron burr the
sitting vice president who killed
the former treasury secretary and
founding father alexander hamilton while
he was vice president that guy oh and
then led an insurrection and tried to
take over the entire country that guy
wasn't a little bit more dangerous maybe
than donald trump who committed the
great evil awful crime of
lowering taxes a little and uh getting
us some conservative justices on the
supreme court well that's the other
thing
that's the other thing for all the
attacks on donald trump that we're
hearing
the man was the most conservative
and the most effective president of my
entire lifetime
roe v wade is no longer the law of the
land
because of donald trump
had hillary clinton become president
had the democrats gotten their way in
2016 or had the squish republicans got
in their way in 2016.
donald trump would not have been
president
you would not have had brett kavanaugh
neil gorsuch amy coney barrett on the
court roe v wade would have been upheld
you would still have 850 000 babies a
year being killed for abortion that's
just one issue
for that alone donald trump is one of
the greatest presidents in american
history
i don't remember the bush administration
that dick cheney helped to lead i don't
remember the bush administration over
overthrowing roe v wade in fact i
remember the bush administration giving
us john roberts now it did give us sam
alito that's great
but the bush administration kind of had
to be strong strong-armed into giving us
decent judges they were trying to
nominate harriet myers and all just a
bunch of really
i just
i'm happy that dick cheney is defending
his daughter that's good for him
but i do not want to be preached to
by the bush administration on what it
means to be a true conservative okay
especially if he's if he's lambasting
trump supporters as somehow not having
principles or not being sufficiently
conservative the trump administration
was much
much better than the bush administration
by pretty much any measure by pretty
much any measure what so ever speaking
of overruling roe v wade
this great news out of indiana following
the overruling of roe following the
dobbs decision indiana lawmakers passed
legislation to ban all abortions
except in the cases of rape or incest
which is really the same thing right
there's not a whole lot of consensual
incest that's going on so except in the
cases of rape or medical emergency
all the other abortions have been banned
which means that 99 plus of abortions
are banned in in indiana this is the
first ban on abortion since roe v wade
was overturned the white house says the
indiana legislature took a devastating
step as a result of the supreme court's
extreme decision to overrule roe v wade
and elimin women eliminate women's
constitutionally protected right to
abortion so blah blah blah wow
we don't like this
indiana is the first step we need all
the other states to do this too let's go
baby
we we talked a lot for especially during
the tea party era about how politics is
downstream of culture we are now in the
culture is downstream of politics era
okay we are we are seeing the political
effects the law as a teacher changing
and shaping culture the minute dobbs
came down you saw these news reports
interviewing young women and young men
who who said with dismay gosh i might
not have so much promiscuous sex anymore
i've really got to think about this
i've got to not just go out and have a
bunch of different sexual partners every
night because i might not have the easy
out of abortion to be able to kill my
kid if a baby is produced so maybe i'll
maybe i'll return to a more traditional
kind of behavior that's more conducive
to my own flourishing and the
flourishing of society you're damn right
that sounds great that sounds like
culture's downstream of politics
indiana's leading the way let's see it
from lots of other states as well
speaking of family values
another great story the hits just keep
on coming
amid
the ongoing lawsuits that are being
leveled against pornhub this is i think
the biggest porn website certainly one
of one of the biggest names in porn it's
owned by a company called mind geek and
i guess they own lots of other
properties and websites too there are
lawsuits now because these porn sites
host child pornography and rape content
and all sorts of illegal content
and in part this is because the the
limits on who can upload what and and
how the videos stay up and how the
videos are taken down they're not really
well defined it's it's not as though
for every video that's uploaded to one
of these websites they're checking
people's id cards making sure people are
over 18 making sure that the women who
are in these videos weren't drugged or
coerced or anything like that so there's
all sorts of
outright illegal material on these
websites furthermore
all of the material is by definition
obscene we have laws against obscenity
in this country we had laws passed in
the late 1990s bipartisan support passed
to limit porn on the internet and
unfortunately a bunch of groomer creepy
judges shot that down
baselessly
so
you could if you wanted if there were
the political will you could take down
these behemoths right now well
the market might be taking down the the
porn websites before even the political
order will visa
is uh is is now suspending ad payments
on pornhub and other mind geek websites
mastercard had already suspended uh use
on pornhub and now they're suspending
use of its card for advertising payments
on other websites owned by mindgeek
the lawsuit in particular right now that
is doing this
is a woman who said that her boyfriend
uploaded a video of her from when she
was 13 years old 13. it's not like we're
talking at 17 and a half here clearly
this girl must have been very very
underage and yet it was it was
proliferating all around these platforms
and so it's a really clear-cut case visa
mastercard they're not doing this as far
as i'm concerned
we should take down the big porn giants
by any means necessary
the political order lawsuits obviously
there's some politics involved here then
there's market forces involved because
the companies don't want to catch the
flack and they're getting activists
calling them and saying you're
facilitating child pornography you're
facilitating rape so they don't want it
all i don't care whatever it is there is
no right to porn
there is no right to make money on the
sex sexual exploitation of women and in
some cases children take it down
by the way not only because some of this
content is very very clearly illegal
even if the content weren't illegal
we should still
fight against porn
why
one
because it's wrong
but two i don't want to just sound like
the church lady here two because it is
harming a huge number of people in this
country every single week in my mailbag
i get so many questions from young men
who are who are talking about how porn
has ruined their lives we read a study
on the show this was a long time ago
there's a study that the average age
that that a young boy is exposed to
hardcore porn on the internet
is like 11 i think
the vast majority of men have looked at
porn at some point in their lives and a
growing number of women have looked at
it and struggled with with the
temptation to look at it as well and
it's really messing them up
you're seeing huge numbers of men who
are experiencing erectile dysfunction
because they've gotten their brains so
turned to scrambled eggs on porn
they they're
they have all sorts of problems in
relationships they're experiencing
depression anxiety
i could go on and i've actually stopped
even reading all of these questions in
the mail bag because they're they're so
repetitive because so many people are
writing in with the exact same problems
and it
porn is a really good issue here because
i i don't think i'm being hyperbolic
when i say high-speed internet porn is
one of the
biggest political problems in america
why because it's in part a technological
problem
20 years ago this did not exist
20 years ago i don't know i guess maybe
you'd say 30 years ago at this point if
you wanted to go look at porn you'd have
to go to the cd part of town and go into
some scuzzy looking shop and you would
there would be enough shame involved in
all of that that you just wouldn't do it
or you'd have to go to the magazine
store and go to the you know the rack in
the back at the top and buy a playboy or
a pentas magazine or whatever now we all
have portals to hell in our pockets okay
or on our laptops or on our ipads or
wherever
and the sort of porn that is available
is
way more intense than your uncle's
playboy from the 70s okay
way way more intense and it there are
a ton of psychological studies on this
it just really messes people up
and if you if you have you just look at
the statistics on it if you've got a
country where the vast majority of
people are in a state of perpetual grave
mortal sin that they can't escape from
that they want to escape from but
they're too addicted to
that is you are not going to have a
flourishing political order you just
can't
a good comparison would be to drugs if
you had a country
where 90 of men and some other large
number of women
were all hooked on heroin all the time
you would not have a good political
order and so i'm all for this wheeled
government power
to stop this stuff
just i would say the same thing for
drugs we didn't get to the brittany
griner story right now
we'll get to we'll get to brittany
griner maybe tomorrow or later on this
week but
so so many people are complaining about
brittany griner because she's being
sentenced to jail for using drugs and
they're saying oh she shouldn't be
sentenced for that long or it shouldn't
be nine years the the sentence in russia
is not unusual it's not like she's just
being selectively prosecuted because
she's an american and it gives them
leverage this just is the punishment for
drugs in russia we used to have much
tougher punishment for drugs in america
we used to have much tougher punishment
for for porn and obscenity in america we
used to have much tougher punishments in
years past and maybe right now you're
trying to grapple with this idea because
you're saying look i don't think we
should have tough drug laws i don't
think we should have tough laws on
obscenity or sex or whatever weird kind
of vice stuff i don't think we should
have any of that but then ask yourself
this question do you think america today
is better is a better country than it
was 20 30 years ago do you really think
that you really think 2022 alters to
your abortion transiting the little kids
everyone
especially on the porn issue totally
messed up on this weird sex stuff
highest rates of drug overdoses ever
average life expectancy declining in the
united states driven in large part by
drug overdoses you're really going to
tell me that all those policies of
liberalizing and letting up and getting
rid of some of those laws you really
think that's worked out i don't think
it's worked out at all they're going to
call us when we want to reinstitute
these kind of rules they're going to
call us authoritarian
fascist illiberal
because what because we want to restore
some of the normal laws that exist
everywhere else in the world that
existed here 20 30 years ago i don't
think so buster i think we got to do
that i think we got to start wielding
politics
not to not to create some utopian
society but just to go back to the much
more sane society that we had not that
long ago i'm michael knowles this the
michael knowles show see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.